so everyone asks Jason about his workout
and what he was eating and I felt that
it's not fair to you so I want to start
with what were you eating on the sect
what was your diet like to maintain the
shape and physicality of directing this
movie you know what I actually need it
to eat as healthy as I can because this
movie is such a huge movie to make
and not just to shoot but but just to
your overall to put it together this
film took like two and a half years of
my life and and you know yeah it's not
just the actors they have to stay in
shape as the director as the captain of
this ship I have to add to make sure
that uh I keep my health and just spends
my spirit up and and the cool thing is
you know the actors on set have a
personal chef to cook for them and kind
of keep them in shape so so they don't
steer off it's that gorging on pasta or
whatever right that's the thing that I
think Jason missed the most was uh
giving up pasta during the photography
of this film
and you know and whatever they were
eating out 2009 as well um the last few
DC movies have been darker and one of
the things I think people are really
responding to about this is that it's
bright and it's fun and it's different
than what's come before can you sort of
talk about that I think this movie is
different even in the immanent outside
of DC just in the general sort of
superhero landscape right because we've
never kind of seen a movie like this
that takes place you know in the in the
underwater world before right at least
not to this level and and you know
people ask me you know you know what is
your inspiration I say I actually took
my inspiration from from the comic book
because that's how the comic book you
know you know that's how the copic books
were and and so uh you know so many
years worth of source material to be
pulling from I felt very lucky to
basically you know be one of the first
people to you know to be able to uh make
a movie about this character that's
really never been done before um I like
that it's just Aquaman's basically story
and that it's mirror Aquaman it's the
Aquaman characters the Aquaman well
exactly Aquaman universe yeah so my
question though is if you could have had
a cameo of another DC character
even just walking in the background in
Maine on the beach which character would
you have liked to have put in good
question I haven't really thought about
that but I imagine you know like at
least in the comic book I feel like the
Atlanteans and and and and the will of
Wonder Woman kind of very similar so I
feel like they they she wouldn't be too
out of place in this film I think yeah
Jason mentioned that he would like in
the sequel to have Wonder Woman and
flash so you know right so my question
though is this is gonna be a big hit I
know it my assuming you're gonna be
involved I'm sure in a sequel have you
already thought what sequel don't talk
to me about sequel it's this movie I
said Ben come on yeah it's gonna be a
big hit I'm very confident okay I'll
leave it there I was gonna ask you a
different question but talk a little bit
about the test screening process and
maybe what you learned from those
screenings
uh-huh and you know what maybe you
removed deleted scenes that just didn't
make the final cut I I mean what I mean
test screenings is almost like a
necessary evil these days for vote for
you know if we're just studio filmmaking
in general and and if you're making
movie for you know for the general
public it's always nice to kind of you
know see how they react to it you know
you know when you're so close in its
kind of it's kind of hard to see the
forest from the trees and it's always
good to kind of get a perspective on it
I've always said that test screenings as
much as I I find them to be a pain that
have continued to save my career time
and time again seriously I mean like for
example saw was supposed to go straight
to video but when that movie was test
screen it tested through the roof and it
made the studio rethink putting it
straight to video and putting it on the
big screen instead and so again and
again you know everything that I've
wanted to do I've you know and people
might not necessarily be so sure but
some of the things I do I would play for
an audience and they would pretty much
always be on the same page as me so so
I'm really grateful for the process and
usually I find what I find is you know
whether you know might make my skiers or
my jokes or my action scenes kind of
play oh if I need to
tighten things up or need to lengthen
other staff just to know just to make
sure that pace is correct
you